his country in a deadlocked war and in
need of recruits 55-year-old Mikila has
decided to put on a uniform and pick up
a
gun well the time has come we need to
end this the young people don't fully
understand their time will come too he's
joining the azof volunteers a unit known
for its far-right fuse and Ultra
nationalism that says it has no problem
attracting new
recruits we need to communicate with
people not to intimidate them everyone
will have to fight sooner or later so
there has to be a reserve but nationally
Ukraine seems to be suffering War
fatigue when the fullscale war broke out
tens of thousands of men eagerly
volunteered to fight but two years on
with the growing realization that it
won't be over anytime soon that
enthusiasm has faded and many of those
first volunteers still on the front
lines are simply
exhausted legis ation is being debated
that would reportedly swell the ranks of
the military by up to half a million but
that would still mean soldiers serving
now not being discharged for 3 years and
many families who regularly Hold Street
protests believe that's unfair we want
demobilization after 18 months there are
some of us who carry the burden of this
war well there are others here at home
who are getting used to the war and
ignoring it with Russia still managing
to find waves of new recruits for its
assaults there's a growing feeling from
these protesters their husbands and Sons
will be lucky to make it home again Rob
McBride Al jazer
keev make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer